For those who do not know, Sophia and I did a
movie together called Soul Plane.
This was actually the first movie.
That you ever did. No, it was the second one
that I ever did. The first one was Paper
Soldiers, but this was supposed to be the
movie that launched my career that put me in
a place of real success.
Jessy Terrero, who I know, you know.
Yes. We both. Snoop Dogg.
What's in that? Snoop.
That. Mo'nique, D.L.
Hughley.
Yes. John Witherspoon.
Yes.
You know that. It was like I want to say like
18 years ago or something.
Maybe longer. 20 years, I think.
Yeah, because it was when I moved.
You're right here. I moved 20 years ago to
Los Angeles.
Yeah, that's that's about the right time.
It sounds right.
20 years ago, it was like one of my first
movies.
So. So let me ask you a question.
For me, that movie, you know, it really was
a pivotal, pivotal moment for me in my
career because although the movie didn't
have box office success because it got
bootlegged, they had a tremendous amount of
success, and it allowed me to really kind of
take my feet, place them in a space of stand
up, build a rapport with an audience, and
like grow.
A fan started believing in, you know, after
that because they were able to see, like, I
didn't even know who you were until I saw
the movie and I was like, oh my God, this
guy is amazing.
And you were so much more handsome at the
time, remember?
Yeah. And younger.
Yeah. Fresher.
Yeah. But you're doing great.
No. Yeah.
Yeah. No. Yeah, absolutely.
It was weird. I think we kind of, I think it
took like, I thought, I thought you were
going, like in the space of a compliment.
And then they say, boom, it just went down.
It was.
A compliment.
Yeah. Well, until you said like that was when
I was younger, I still felt.
Like, well, I'm not lying.
It's a fact you were younger 20 years ago.
Yes.
Well, I mean, it depends on how you look at
me. Well.
I'm 50 now.
I was, like, fresh at that time.
Now I'm like.
Sofia, you look.
Great.
Yeah, I'm serious.
But I'm 50. You look great inside.
I'm 50.
Inside your 50.
No, actually, no. Inside.
I feel like I'm younger, but everything.
What is that? What just happened?
No! Stop it!
No!
Yeah. It's like everything is starting to
like. No.
You know, it's like.
You look phenomenal.
Phenomenal. My question was going to be,
what did that movie do for you?
What did what did Soul Plane do for you at
that point in your career? It got
me money.
Yeah, just pretty much.
That's it. Yeah. Just got you money.
Did opportunities come because of Soul
Plane?
I created a lot of, you know, friends there,
which was amazing. And also, I learned a lot
to be on a set doing a movie because it was
like one of my first movies.
Then I worked a couple of times with Tyler
Perry. So I think, yes, like, you know, I
think then I became part of more movies that
were more for, you know, black people, Latin
people, you know, that they were including
us. So that was a great time for me.
That's what I think that that movie did for
me.
And you. You came from Univision, right?
I remember you were you were a very big in
world of Univision.
How long were you in that ecosystem?
Well, I've been working since I was like 17
years old, but really in Univision.
I started working like when I was 22, and I
think I've never stopped, you know, really,
since.
22, you've been going nonstop?
Yeah, nonstop.